ふーん
寒いこんにちははじめ社長ですツイッターみましょう
文房具紹介やらないのお受験前のすすめの知りたいです
文房具かちょっとまた見ておきます大跳びで今日なんですけどもうね化石親分がですね
スーパーの話を南下動画にしてたんで全く別なんですけど僕が
ユーチューバーになる前ですね皆さん黒何してたかって言うからの僕大学生
をしながらなライトをしまくっていました
実はねそのバイトをしてたんですけどまぁちょっとその場合どの頃のねちょっと話とか
をしてみよっかなんて思いますが皆さんの中のバイトをしてる方しようとしてる方とか
by いると思うんで何かの参考になればいいかなっていう感じでちょっと俺のバイト
話でも
聞いてくれや僕ですね一番バイトで頑張ってたのはですね本目にです
by ずじゃぁ
してなかったらいいんですけど本音ドバイ立つたかな馬鹿にされそうな気がしするん
ですけどをまぁ僕も馬鹿にしてたところありました僕人生初めてのバイトがコンビニで
した理由わー
辛そうだったからだってそうでしょなんかコンビニのデイサーんとかバイトとか見たん
だろピット方はそして
ピッピかつ車さああ車アーサー線朝したみたいな感じでなくて誰でもできるんじゃない
かなと思ってコンビニのバイトを始めました愛楽二年生の夏くらいからバイトを始め
ましたなんかねあのサークルも62数も部活を知る
でもなくはヘロヘロと大学1年生は過ごしてたんで愛としなきゃって思って始めます
いやーコンビニなんてちょろい書等長でしょと思って入ったんですけど黙想厳しかった
です何の巡り合わせかはよくわかんないんですけど僕がそんな働き数えるとコンビニが
ですね全国的に見て全国的に見てなんかすごい有名なコンビニだったらしくてサービス
てく接客
くっのあのなんかも斑点みたいな研修とかでビデオ見せられるんですけどもそのビデオ
で映ってた女の人がもうその店で働いてたりしてて
うわ俺えっ
じゃないどうか思いだからそういうちょっとあの接客レベル max 最高のコンビニ
で多く働き始めることになっちゃったんですけどもそれぞれのコンビニでバイト行って
なんかその後お姉さんお姉さんと一緒にバイト入ったんですけども何もわからないんで
とりあえずその上でピピッと施設を袋に入れてくださいって言われてもう袋に入れた
出棺もめちゃくちゃ怒られて何してるぞおっかしー
んじゃそれを怒られちゃったんですよ怖かったなんですなぜかと言うところなんかもう
握るといろいろあったんですけどもいえる順番を間違えちゃってなんかを握れる潰れ
ちゃいそうなんでカバーしてたから来られるっていう今考えたら次は何か普通のことに
なって思ってるんですけど初めてのバイトだったんですねそういうことはまったく
わからなくて本日の物を袋に詰めることで怒らねえ
[ __ ]で怒られ神客車時も
なきゃいけた入ってバイトしようと思ったときにも怒らね仕事が遅くて行われ充電器を
見せて行われ声がついてきて怒られもう本当に米でこんなに怒られるのってくれ
めちゃくちゃ怒られました
えっ構内てますってほんとバックレてやろうかなとかめちゃくちゃ思ったしミスちゃん
にその給料が見合ってなかったって思ってて宇宙なんだっけあの時確か730円とかな
めちゃくちゃ安い給料で俺なんでこの怒られたからやってんだろって言いながらそれで
もやっぱりお店のブランドを守るために行われたことちゃんと聞いておられて怒られて
怒られて3か月も死ぬほど怒られて3か月後にだいぶちょっとコーナ人で切ってある
程度そのお店のないととしてちゃんと家と動けるようになり始めたかなっていう感じ
でしたもうすごいですよあのコンビニって後年かお客さん
入ってくるじゃないですかあのよくいるあの普通の t さんだったら何かしながら
いらっしゃいませ
いらっしゃいませんって言うんですけど僕の働いたらコミュにはもう
いらっしゃいませんこの腕をコースでこうするんですよお客さんがレジの前にきた瞬間
ずっとこうやっていらっしゃいませんってもうやってますたねそれぐらいも積極に眼睛
は本当に何かめちゃ曲厳しくても背筋をぴんとして昆布流を事業してありがとうござい
ました
金木食うぞルーツですいかがでしょうかいかがでしょうか
いらっしゃいませ例えば軟骨入りつくでもに準備でいいからでしょうか
いかがでしょうか感じでめちゃくちゃバイトを頑張ってますそうだからねなんかそう
いうのを見てると他のコンビニ行って店員さんが何か言っちゃったらやってるとマジ
お前ちゃんとやれあーって思っちゃうわけなんですよねちょっと慣れてコンビニ行っ
たらそのコンビに乗って23- a 偏差というか
極めれば
極めるほどコンビニっておもしれーなってきてたのがバイトの始まりでしたねコンビニ
でゴミ箱ついてるんですけど
ゴミ箱があふれることはまずないです増えればに絶対ナックス c 例えばこう
商品が並んでるとするじゃないですかここ通路ねこうやって商品が並んでるとするじゃ
ないですか
お客さんが何が1個買うとポテンツとかだったらこれちょっと空いちゃうじゃないです
この隙間をお客さんが商品を買ってありがとうございました
ドアから出って言った瞬間急いでここまで行ってポテチはこうやって寄せて前に出す
これ前鎮と言います御膳亭作業必ずやってました
頭皮をキレイに見せたいんで盛りことを取られたりしてこの場所が空いてると
術攻作業を欠かさずやっていました多分最強レベルでしっかりしたコンビニだったなっ
て
とか今だと思っていますなんで僕は何か大学卒業してその一般企業に就職しないだ
ユーチューバーやらせてもらってるんですけど守り年間以上か
約2年間5をコンビニで働かせてもらって何だろうその接着というか人に対する接し方
というかサービス業というかちゃんとちゃった
には出てないんですけどある程度社会性を身につけられたのかなって思います何か
ちゃんと働くってこういうことだってよっていうのを身に付けられているか気がします
普通に10連勤とかしてましたからねコンビニいる方が長いみたいな生活があったとき
もあります
なんかね by とはねぇその楽して稼げるバイトとかもいっぱいあると思うんです
けど経路をしても安かっ
バイトの方の僕はず分のためになったかなって思います市長としていろんなことを磨い
てもらえたかなって思いました
なんであのすごい厳しかったしそうこられたしなんでコンビニバイトルカナックス怒ら
れたんだろうと思ったんですけど僕は今すごい
監査しております黒証みたいなのがありまして僕そのサービスマスターても選ばれたん
ですよ全国の
店員さんでも限られた人しかするなれないらしくてなんかその本みりんの本社の人の
抜き打ちでそれに行き的になれまして全国のコンビニの店員さんがそのスーパークルー
だけを集められて研修みたいなのがあったんですけど
ディズニーランドでディズニーランドってサービス業のなんか
頂点なんですよで人のキャストさん達って本当にすごくてもう来てくだ
だったかとみんな絶対者は線して改装っていう気持ちでお仕事してるんですよねあの
サービス業接客の頂点っていうかもう模範にしたいっていうのはもうディズニーランド
とディズニーシーとああいう場所になってて全国のトップグルーを集められた研修って
いうのはディズニーランドでの研修だった
何人か静岡県の代表として僕が選ばれてずにーらんどに入って全国にそのトップコンビ
に rain さんたちと一緒にディズニーランドの研修を受けさせていただいたりも
してました
そういうすごいやすくて辛がったんですけどやって良かったなって思ったことありまし
たよって話ですまあ逆にそれが裏目に出た時もあったんですけどね
なんかコンビ
で働いてバイト入りまくて10年金どうかしてると毎回来る人とか分かるんですよまあ
毎日今1クールな毎日この時間に来るなーあんてあなた箱なら42万ながらハイライト
ステップでハイライトうううーーんなんかそういうな画像ねえさんがいるんですけども
なんかねめっちゃ入ってる時にめちゃくちゃ可愛いんだろうきたんですよ
めちゃくちゃ可愛いよなーっ
いいありがとうございました体だが次の日も帰って来てだしてます三日目は知らせ
めっちゃくるんですよめっちゃ来てくれててやったぞコンビニのバイト
楽しい思ってたんですけどある日そのお客さんの方を会見してあった後何か僕は戻って
きてレシートを持ってたんですよ
レシート急に僕に渡されてすいません連絡先を教え
てくださいと言われたんですよいきせでよかったと思ったんですけど本当に昆明に忠誠
を使ってまして
お店なことしかも考えられなかったんですっごいオせたかったんですよぶー楽すごい
取りだっためちゃくさんも連絡来から時めちゃくちゃ美味しかったんですけども
申し訳ございません業務中ですまでと言って断りましたセクター
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
バッハ